if you want to support more content on
this channel and do some Detroit
smashing at the same time check out our
merch store link in the description
limited time only what is up everybody
its Anna Mack here for anime uproar and
in this video we will be talking about a
massive plot twist that has just been
revealed in the latest chapters of the
boku no hero manga and the new evidence
that has emerged about da B's true
identity some of these James Bond double
agent spy twists definitely caught me by
surprise and on top of what we've
learned we also got some additional
clues about da B's identity that are
just insane and could have staggering
implications on the plot we actually
just ran a poll about what type of MHA
videos you guys want to see next here on
the channel and a video on da be won by
a decent margin so here we go thank you
for participating and if you want to
take part in future polls like this one
be sure to follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar if you enjoyed
the MHA content on this channel you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and Detroit smash that
notification bell naturally this video
will contain manga spoilers since the
anime is behind the manga in terms of
the story so this is your warning
proceed with caution so what do we know
about dobby so far we know that dobby
was inspired by stains ideology to join
the league of villains so we know that
he is not motivated by money fame or a
desire to kill just for the sake of
killing this suggests that something
happened in his life that led him to
sympathize with stain something in his
life led dobby to conclude that the
current hero society is corrupt and
filled with fake heroes we also know
that dobby refuses to give his real name
to anyone and he was willing to fight
shigaraki to the death rather than
reveal his true name finally we know
that Dhabi's quark is a flame and based
quark but the color of the flames is
blue rather than the traditional red or
orange the nature of Dhabi's quark has
resulted in extensive speculation within
the boku no hero fandom and maybe the
single most power
her fan theory out there is that dobby's
father is actually ng Todoroki aka the
flame hero and ever since children often
inherit their quirks from their parents
and since endeavour has a quirk that
allows him to generate and manipulate
flames and he can even turn his flames
blue when he increases their intensity
it isn't hard to jump to the conclusion
that Bobby's quirk is a variation of
endeavors because endeavor is Dhabi's
real father this would explain why Dobby
refuses to reveal his real name if his
last name is Todoroki then he would want
to keep that hidden since endeavour is
the symbol of the type of fake hero that
he hates instead of worrying about
helping people and ever is primarily
concerned with being the strongest and
surpassing all might and he goes so far
as to mistreat his own wife and children
in an attempt to make his son short to
surpass all mic'd for endeavor at least
in the early parts of the story it is
all about his own personal ego rather
than the greater good of society but
this is not all ever since Dobby was
first introduced in the story we've been
getting hints here and there that there
is some connection between Dobby and the
Todoroki family Dobby has roughly the
same eye color as endeavour and as one
of show toes eyes on top of that during
the Forrest training camp arc Dobby
makes it a point to address short Otaki
by name and to mock him as if he had
some sort of special interest in short
oh then in the latest chapters in a
massive twist we learned that Hawkes the
current number 2 pro hero has actually
been working as a double agent
pretending to collaborate with the
League of villains while reporting on
their activities back to the heroes
Hawkes has been secretly communicating
with Dobby and the fact that endeavour
was attacked by a normal while out and
about with Hawkes was actually part of a
plan that hawks and Dobby came up with
together
although hawks did not know how strong
the normal would be and the attack was
supposed to occur the next day at a
factory outside the city and not in the
middle of the city also Dobby seems to
not have known that the hero Hawks would
bring was endeavour himself from what
we've seen so far Hawk says goal as a
double agent is to make
villains thing that he is loyal to the
league so that he can get information
about them and so that he can ultimately
meet the boss meaning she gerak and I
assume that the whole point of the plan
is to get shigaraki to trust Hawkes and
reveal himself so that the heroes can
take him down when he meets endeavour
face to face dobby seems clearly excited
by the prospect of facing him and he
even suggests that the two of them need
to have a chat and ever does not
recognize Dobby as anyone more than a
member of the League of villains who
killed the sand heroes smash and we
don't learn a lot more at this point
because their chat is interrupted by the
number 5 pro hero miracle and dobby
decides to retreat but before he leaves
Dobby tells endeavour that they'll have
to continue their chat later and he
tells him not to kick the bucket before
they meet again and then calls him by
his real name Angie Todoroki just like
he did with shot though many arcs
earlier again this makes it clear that
dobby has a special interest in endeavor
he wants to face off against him in
particular and he even tells it not to
die until they meet again because they
need to have some sort of chat at the
very end of chapter 191 Dobby remembers
when the sand hero snatch asked him
during their battle whether he ever
stops to think about how the families of
his victims feel Dobby didn't answer
this question during his battle with
snatch in chapter 160 but now he finally
answers that by saying I thought so hard
about it I went crazy I think that this
is a very meaningful statement by Dobby
not just a throwaway line dobby's
victims over the months and years
include petty criminals and other lesser
known individuals but they also include
pro heroes like snatch so what does
Dobby mean when he says that thinking
about the families of his victims made
him go crazy I don't think that he is
talking about the families of petty
criminals that he has killed because if
he really cared about their families and
felt remorse that he could just stop
killing them I think that this statement
is referring to the families of parole
heroes and the suffering that they have
to go through because of the pro hero
lifestyle Pro heroes often have to make
massive sacrifices for their profession
and their families pay the price
great example of this is of course ng
Todoroki aka and ever he became so
obsessed with being the number one
parole hero and surpassing all might
that he married sholto's mother
primarily because of her quirk he wanted
to create an offspring with an
incredibly powerful quirk by combining
his wife's ice quirk with his own flame
quirk we know that Sholto has an older
sister and two older brothers but it
wasn't until shota was born that
endeavour finally felt that he had a
child with a quark that was strong
enough to one day surpass all mine while
we have already seen shot of sister and
his middle brother we have yet to meet
his oldest brother and we do not know
his name so could it be that what dobby
means by this statement is that he is a
member of endeavours family that he is
endeavours son and the suffering that
endeavor put him through in his quest to
surpass all might is the thing that
drove him crazy and turned him into a
villain is dobby show toes oldest
brother who after seeing endeavour
abused their mother to the point that
she was committed to a mental
institution decided to run away from
home reject the hero society and adopt
staines philosophy we've met one of
shuttle's older brothers not soooo who
is a 19 year old college student you
could say the Natsu has a similar frame
and hairstyle to Dobby but not so is not
Dobby because their appearance is
definitely not the same and not so is
shown to be watching the showdown
between endeavour and Dobby together
with his sister Fuyumi but show toto
rocky has another brother the oldest
brother who has not been introduced and
whose name we still don't know
so could Dobby be endeavours oldest son
since endeavor tells us that Shoto is
the only one of his children who has a
quirk powerful enough to surpass all
might it is safe to assume that
endeavour was unhappy with the abilities
of his older children and he probably
mistreated them because of that
if Dobby is the oldest brother who
abandoned the family because of how he
was treated by his father it would make
perfect sense for him to say that
thinking about the families of pro
heroes is what drove him crazy and it
would also make perfect sense for him to
sympathize with stains ideology because
endeavour is the perfect example of a
fake hero who doesn't want to be a hero
to help others instead he is doing a
to satisfy his own selfish ego and while
he pretends to be heroic in public he is
actually cruel and abusive towards his
own family in his private life but if
this is the case and Dobby is sholto's
oldest brother then why doesn't Sholto
recognize him and why doesn't Endeavour
recognize his own son even if he left
the family a long time ago it seems
unlikely that no one in the family would
recognize him especially if Dobby scars
are real and he got them as a child
since that would be an even bigger
tip-off about who he really is all of
the Todoroki children are also shown as
having either white or red hair or some
kind of combination of those two colors
so for him to be one of them dobby's
black hair doesn't really fit the only
way that Dobby could be show toes oldest
brother is if he is wearing a disguise
meaning that his hair is dyed and his
purple scars are not real but part of
the disguise the oldest son abandoning
the family because of his father's abuse
could turn out to be a major reason why
shota's mother eventually ended up in a
mental institution
so if we can accept that Dobby is
wearing a disguise then it is very
possible that he could be endeavours
eldest son and sholto's oldest brother
if however Dhabi's appearance is not a
mask and he really looks like that then
my guess is that he could be sholto's
half-brother a child of Endeavour and
another woman perhaps from a previous
marriage or relationship that endeavor
hasn't seen in a very long time so he
wouldn't have seen Dobby since he was
very small and therefore he wouldn't be
able to recognize him in this case Dobby
could have inherited his dark hair from
this other woman and if he was a child
from a previous relationship then he
likely would never have met Soto and his
other siblings so it's no wonder that
they would not recognize him knowing
Endeavour if he had been in a
relationship with another woman and
Dobby was their child he is definitely
the type of person to abandon Dobby if
he felt that Dobby was unworthy of
surpassing all might the fact that
endeavour chose sholto's mom
specifically because of her strong quirk
could mean that he tried having children
before and this experience taught him
that he must handpick his partner and
make sure that she has the strongest
possible quirk otherwise he will not
achieve the desired results as was
potentially the case with Dobby
and again if Dobby was abandoned as a
child by his father who then
to become one of the top-ranked pro
heroes after starting a new family
without him it would make perfect sense
for Dobby to despise the hero society
and to sympathize with stains ideology
Dobby would be ashamed of his biological
connection to endeavor and so it would
also make perfect sense for him to hide
his real name I didn't always ascribe to
this theory of dobby being shota's
brother or half-brother but at this
point in the manga with all of the clues
that we have been getting I am 99% sure
that Dobby is endeavours son and either
the oldest brother or an estranged
half-brother of Shortell Todoroki and
with that said i can't wait to find out
more about all of this as the manga
progresses but let me know what you guys
think do you think that Dobby is
endeavours son and that the manga is
slowly leading up to making that massive
reveal feel free to give me your own
theories arguments and counter-arguments
down below I always love hearing from
you if you enjoyed the MHA videos on
this channel and you want to see more
you can let me know by leaving a like
and if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and Detroit smash
that notification bell also don't forget
to check us out on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar as always thank you all
so much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you